the town's burning everyone's in danger
and I'm losing my Riverdale loving mind
come freak out with me on Sweetwater
secrets
hey river babes
I'm your host Lee anti-glare and this is
the Sweetwater Secrets after-show for
episode 2 11 chapter 34 judgement night
now all those who were hyperventilate
while watching this week's episode
please raise your fangs okay now today
I'll be bringing you exclusive answers
from Riverdale Starz Skeet Ulrich and
Vanessa Morgan about the Serpent's most
shocking moments and then I'm gearing up
to go full-on riot mode and hisses and
kisses but first I'm going to do my best
to quickly recap the most insane moments
of the episode and there are a lot of
them in the blue and gold breakdown deep
breaths y'all here we go the episode
picked up right where we left off with
the black hood viciously chasing Cheryl
around her house but she quickly
transformed from a damsel in distress
to avenging Archer it was awesome I only
miss when I mean to she shot the black
hood in the shoulder and once we
fast-forwarded through the blood at the
Cooper's and a dead doctor and what was
supposed to be how Cooper's hospital bed
the truth was officially revealed
there's a black hood
hey why's Hal Cooper all along you guys
he played some creepy old home videos of
himself as a little boy and revealed
some truly bizarre and confusing story
about grandpappy blossom and the black
me on the subsequent cover-up of the
conway family murders and none of this
makes any sense it was a little
underwhelming but Alison buddy teamed up
to take out how but don't get too happy
he's still alive unfortunately and was
later arrested but they truly vile part
is that there's now some copycat black
hood out there and he tried to kill Fred
Andrews again not to worry what's that
saying
TGIF DSB P V thank God for dill saving
bulletproof vests
meanwhile the Pennbrook small fry was
hell-bent on getting revenge for his
father's death but rather than
confronting Hiram papa poutine son
decided to attack the lodge ladies
instead luckily Hermione's sprang into
mama bear mode grabbed Hiram's hidden
gun and shot small fry four times in the
chest and last but certainly not least
we need to talk about the Serpent's now
after riding around Riverdale the
Serpent's quickly discovered that penny
Peabody and the Goonies were back in
town and they kidnapped Tony now Cheryl
came to her girl's rescue untie her
you serpent hag and the Serpent's all
gathered round for a game plan against
the bullies f:p then got a call saying
that fangs had passed away and the group
prepared for a battle but not wanting a
slaughter to happen jug had contacted
Hyrum the mastermind behind the Ghoulies
returned and offered him a deal jugheads
life for the Serpent's safety now the
episode ended with fp' carrying what
seemed to be his son's lifeless body and
then I panicked and I blacked out and I
woke up on the set of Sweetwater secrets
with Skeet Ulrich so I can ask him about
the fate of Jughead take a look that
final scene with you holding what looks
to be jugheads the lifeless body when
you read that in the script what was
your reaction I hope he diets I was like
I wonder how heavy Cole is in fact
actually what they called me and they
were like can you carry coal from the
writers room like weeks before they even
wrote it they were like can you carry
coal well he was not they're not giving
me much credit uh yeah and I was like
yeah I can carry him and they were like
oh can you go over to his trailer and
send us a picture of you carrying him
and they actually sent the PA to come
like take video of me picking coal up
yeah but I mean in terms of reading it's
it's traumatic and it's every father's
worst nightmare you know their kids
being hurt and I can tell that the fans
right now are probably hyperventilating
should they be worried that was the
massive cliffhanger yeah they should be
worried now while we all try to process
that let's move into you seven seconds
in heaven now since this episode was
mostly focused on giving us all heart
attacks and seeing how many dead bodies
we could count the romance was a little
light this week but we did get this
super-sweet barchi Ellie I love you I
love you too
and of course bug-head B of us all the
feels with this haunting phone call I
never stopped loving you but at least
the Shoni fans were treated to a happy
moment when Cheryl channeled her inner
Katniss Everdeen and stood up to penny
Peabody
now here's what Vanessa Morgan had to
tell me about filming Cheryl's romantic
rescue mission to save Tony and what
this could mean for their future in the
finale and you please talk about the
Cheryl rescuing Tony seen her coming in
with her bow and arrow so amazing what
was it like filming that I thought it
was so badass because you know I'm
sitting down like yeah there's my girl
she's holding up her bow and arrow like
a boss and she saves me from a bunch of
gang members just like that that was
pretty awesome and she looked like a
badass doing in her outfit was a bomb
after Cheryl saves Tony she goes to the
white worm she's like sitting there
while the serpents are all having their
meeting and she kind of just slithered
right in and looked very at home with
them so what can you what can you tease
about that I think that she looks great
with the serpents I think she'll stay
with the serpents to just really have a
family so maybe she's enjoying herself
you know maybe she's feeling a little
bit at home with us
and now let's sink our fangs into dances
and kisses first and most importantly in
hisses that one is going to the
mind-blowing facts but Jughead is he
dead I refuse to believe the FP is
holding his son's lifeless body no I
just know his Estelle's
goober lame reasoning for being the
black hood this is a town
sinners that was way too hard to follow
and Alice's right you're just a pathetic
hypocrite and how dare you try to blame
your sadistic serial killer ways I'm
Betty's good-hearted Jubilee speech also
why didn't you reveal what you did with
chick I mean I don't really care but I
also don't like lingering questions and
if you have any lingering black hood
questions like I do then head on over to
ETA on line to read my exclusive
interview with Hal himself riverdale
star Lachlan Munroe where I grilled him
on everything black hood related now
keeping it going with hisses hisses to
the fact that things died you know that
bullet wound looked fatal but it was
also a little shocking that they
announced this huge news with just a
little phone call you know Alice may say
if it bleeds it leads
but with Riverdale I say nobody no
believe it for now hisses 2fp for firing
the serpent's up and not listening to
jugheads good advice to stay away from
the ghouls I also did not appreciate FPS
lane reasoning for moving forward with
their plans we already voted and extra
hisses to the fact that there's
apparently another black hood out there
stop attacking Fred Andrews I don't know
who you are but I do know that this
reveal had better be good
hisses to Hyrum for pre writing that
aweful October Surprise article about
his own wife's affair with Fred Andrews
you're a vile husband and I'm officially
launching the hashtag free Hermione
campaign hiss she deserves better
switching over to kisses that one is to
Alice for telling how that F P is a
better man than he'll ever be you're
damn right and for using one of those
fireplace pokey things to smack Hal in
the face get the fireplace poker right
there and just whack my foot
sidenote why do all TV characters always
use those fireplace tools for weapons my
fireplace is electric I don't have those
what am I supposed to do if someone ever
attacks me I can't just flip the switch
kisses to Cheryl for rescuing her BAE
from penny Peabody's clutches more
slipping in with the serpent's
seamlessly and for being Riverdale's red
arrow you have not failed this city BAE
kisses to the fact that small-fry killed
Andre now don't get me wrong I'm not
sending kisses to a man's death
I'm sending kisses to the fact that I'm
finally relieved that Hiram fired
Smithers because if he had still been
working at the Pembroke then it would
have been his blood all over that
gorgeous marble floor instead of Andres
I love you Smithers kisses to Veronica
for putting Hiram in his place enter
Hermione for protecting her daughter and
turning small fries into mashed potatoes
kisses to Kevin and moose for clutching
each other when the Ghoulies attacked
Pop's and three additional smooches to
Sheriff Keller FP and Fred were rolling
up to pops and being the dilfs who save
the day we're almost done we're almost
done we still have the Riverdale season
two finale left and I honestly don't
know if they're going to be able to top
this amazing episode now check back with
you next week for our very last preview
episode of Sweetwater secrets for
episode 222 chapter 35 brave new world
where I will have a special surprise for
you
but right now give this video like and
then hit the comments to tell me your
top hisses and kisses of this
mind-blowing episode who do you think
the second black hood is which character
stole the show and do you really think
that Jughead is dead tawny now adore you
to pieces river babes
[Music]